talk to me about your new podcast with
dustin i feel like
there are definitely a lot of bachelor
pods out there but you know what made
you want to start your own
hey i'm peter webber and i'm dustin
kendrick you might know us
from a small reality tv show that we're
on once upon a time we both filled out
applications to find love on national
television
but we had no idea where that journey
would take us so you know i had moved to
new york
in january of this year just always been
a lifelong dream
always i've loved new york city and
dustin ended up moving in with me uh
becoming my roommate
um and i really lucked out with that uh
but it all worked out and when he moved
in he
had brought the idea to me hey man we
should we should start a podcast and
kind of just
uh talk about two bachelors essentially
you know
moving to the city together and um our
experiences and all that and just kind
of you know unveiling the curtain for
you know any of our followers to kind of
follow
our our journey along and i was up for i
thought it could be a fun idea and
um you know we didn't want to make it
obvious you know there are a lot of like
you said a lot of bachelor podcasts we
don't want to make it
um centered around that we definitely
have a little bit where we do talk on it
and we know we give our
you know our followers um a little taste
of that but
mainly it's just kind of following our
every day to like every day-to-day life
in new york city and why we love it so
much and inspire people to kind of fall
in love with the city as well
that's amazing so it's not um it's not
really just
recapping the bachelor it's actually
more of like a peek into your as the
lives of new york
yeah exactly we uh it's mainly about
following just the adventures the
craziness like we we're real with
everyone like we don't hold back and
uh there's a lot of crazy you know stuff
that happens but it's fun
and uh we we're trying to be just as
real with people as possible and
uh i think they appreciate that but uh
we definitely yeah
you know talk a little bit on the show
you have to um right and we don't mind
it you know it did a lot for us and
we're very grateful for for the
opportunities it gave us
for sure so are you digging new york i
freaking love new york man i miss it
like crazy right now
i haven't been back in about a month uh
you know being here for training in
denver but yeah
uh it's the to me the most beautiful
city in the world
it's truly like people ask me why i love
it so much it's just it's an adventure a
new adventure every single day and you
don't know what's gonna happen
and that i love about it that magic that
energy is incredible was there also
a part of you where you're like you know
what it'll be also awesome to have a
platform so i can
address things directly whether that's
you know stuff that's going on in your
personal life or any related bachelor
news
like how much tea are you spilling on
this podcast
yeah honestly that was i never like
looked at it as that kind of um
like that benefit of having a podcast i
know honestly never even had the thought
of having a podcast it only came to
because it dusted
um but yeah i mean i guess there have
been a couple times where
it's offered me a platform to kind of
answer things or kind of give
my take on a story or whatnot um which i
guess has been kind of convenient
for sure i mean obviously i asked
because as you mentioned on your podcast
you
addressed comments that your ex had made
about your breakup
uh which kind of prompted her to post a
nearly like nine minute youtube video
i don't understand when you end badly
with someone you would think that they
would just try to respect you
a little bit and just um you know go
their way instead of reaching out to
my friends are you surprised based on
you know the breakup how it's all
starting to play out right now
i honestly i have nothing else to say uh
there there will be no you know um
response for me anymore like i said
everything i had to say
i i feel like it's been beaten to death
but
if i don't know why people keep talking
about it um you know i've moved on
and i truly truly wish nothing but the
best for kelly and
um it's tough when you have a
relationship obviously in the public eye
and people invest in it um and they're
gonna have opinions and they're gonna
say things again
no one knows the full full story except
the two people involved just like any
relationship
well listen no matter who you are
breakups are really tough uh this seemed
like a tough one
what would you say is the thing that
you're going to take away from that time
with kelly
i freaking love my time with kelly i i
truly i say to everyone i think that was
the best relationship i ever had
and just because it didn't work out and
yeah and
when you break up it just gets
uncomfortable and and weird and hurtful
and whatnot but
uh so many things that i just i took
from that and i learned and
um and just she
it was the first time i think i really
felt like she had my back and like
everything and we went through so much
together like it was so much
criticism or whatnot and just uh so much
that we had to go through together and
it was really like i had never really
experienced a relationship where you
kind of go through the fire
with someone um together and like the
strength that that brings
you to and and um just being able to
appreciate like how good of a person she
is
and uh how how much i could truly feel
like she wanted the best for me like
i learned a lot about what i want you
know obviously we weren't meant to be
and that's okay and and it is what it is
but i learned
truly like what i want in someone and
the person that hopefully i get to end
up with you know for the rest of my life
and i feel like you really get to know
someone and also a a
a relationship in the middle of a
pandemic too because that was going for
sure
i mean you guys really did have a lot
stacked against you if you will but
uh uh i'm curious would you ever watch
bachelor in paradise if kelly was on it
no that'd be yeah it'd be very hard to
watch it'd be uncomfortable
um you know i don't i don't want
whether it's right or wrong i'm someone
that i try to
distance myself kind of as much as
possible um just because
at least in that you know the months
following a breakup especially when it's
public
um i don't want to see what they're
doing i don't want to see who they're
dating or whatnot like
i think anyone kind of feels a little
icky and that you know it stings a
little bit it's just i mean that's
natural um i i don't even know if she's
on to be honest on this
most recent season that's coming up um
right now for sure that'd be very
difficult for me to watch you know next
year
a little easier but yeah that would
that'd be weird are you dating right now
are you at least open to it
man i have zero time to date right now i
that's the last and well let me say i
i'm looking forward to dating i really
am like kind of getting back there it
was a weird kind of like
couple months coming to new york and
everything with the breakup and
having to deal with all these articles
about it and i
just you know it's a weird place i was
in a weird head place
um i've now since moved on from that
i've you know i'm
stoked on life man i'm freaking high on
life i got my dream job now and i'm in
training for that right now
and i can't wait to get back to new york
and enjoy kind of like the second half
of the summer here when i'm done with
training but
um right now i have all i focus on is
studying
i will say that i i definitely feel like
i'm i'm ready to get back out there and
uh i'm i haven't been able to say that
in a very long time so i'm excited for
that
um that it's exciting to hear actually
uh but you have been hanging out with
victoria justice a lot is there anything
going on there that we need to know
about
do we need to know about something no
vic and i we go way back we we're on it
we've been
and a lot of people i guess don't know
it but we've been childhood friends um
you know since i was like 12 and she was
like 11. uh
so we know each other for a while we've
since kind of reconnected in the last
couple of years a little bit more
um but now she's just an amazing person
great friend and yeah we've
had a lot of fun you know together and
our families are really close so it's
been good
knowing that you are open to dating and
to find love again
would you ever do the show again would
you ever be the bachelor if they asked
no no no that that is you know
the experience it was so many great
things you know so many tough things to
go through
i'll never say i regret it like i'm so
grateful for it the
person i am now is is so much different
than
you know the man i was coming on the
show and i'm thankful for that i've
grown
immensely um but that's kind of
i think for me just kind of run its
course and
not to say like i i'm open to dating
anyone
but to me it's a there's an attract
there's an attractive thing in my mind
of
maybe you know a relationship that's not
public anymore you know again who knows
the next person i meet could be in the
public eye too and i'm not
opposed to that but um it'd be nice to
maybe have it more private
and do you still believe in that in that
process like is there any advice you
would give to a lead
signing on to do the show to find love
for me i don't think
it can work just like i realized i
needed more time than
you know 30 at the end of it was
probably like 30 35 hours of cumulative
time with the person you're gonna end up
with for me like
that wasn't realistic or like legit um
i need more time with someone i need to
actually have like legit real
conversations and not kind of like
you know scripted conversations um but
for some people it does work and it has
worked
and it's a great um example for for love
but what if you were enticed to travel
to mexico for paradise would that be an
option is that something
because you could have more time it
could be fun to do in paradise
man i i guess that's the one kind of uh
the one experience of the show i haven't
i haven't tried it maybe
third time's the charm maybe that's what
i i need to do i don't know um
if you're game i think they'd love to
have you hey i'll take
take a seat plane down there and land on
the water and uh and we'll see
we'll see what happens you never say
never i don't know you know
your entrance is already planned i can
see you're the opening credits with you
flying into uh
mexico it's perfect yeah it goes yeah
never say never
yeah well listen there's so much to
catch up with you on i do want to move
on to chris harrison
have you guys been in touch at all since
he stepped away from the franchise
you know i i've texted him we've text a
couple times back and forth i haven't
seen him in person
um you know unfortunately i listen i
i i really do i think the world of chris
like i've had nothing but great
you know memories with him if anything i
think it's just it's sad
um you know it's sad for kind of every
all parties involved and
and then just kind of have it and the
way it did um with
him having having been such a prominent
role in that franchise and
really i think being the biggest reason
why it grew to be as big as it has
become
it's sad to see you know uh do you feel
like it was the right move
him walking away you know i to be honest
i i can't even speak on that for sure i
don't even know if he was the one that
walked away or if he was you know
let go i don't know did you feel like he
should have stayed or they should have
wanted him to be
the host of the bachelor for a couple
more seasons
i do i i think listen i
ain't nobody's perfect that's a
understatement right
um yeah the show the show is gonna is
gonna miss him
i i just i think they do i think ratings
i mean those don't lie
uh they're kind of already showing that
and
it's just again it's sad for all parties
involved um
i know chris i know chris is a good
person and
you know i wish him nothing but the best
going forward with whatever he does
but i think the show is going to regret
letting him go i do
so what did you think of tasia and
caitlyn kind of stepping in this season
of the bachelorette as mentors and hosts
i love them i um i've actually not met
caitlin in person
i've met tasha in for instance she's
she's such a sweetheart i've talked with
caitlin like on zooms and i know jason
um so listen i think they're they're
doing a great job
um no one's ever gonna replace chris
harris and that's that's obvious
uh just you kind of can't when he's been
so cemented in that role
but uh yeah i think what what it does
offer is a cool
you know unique twist um you know it's
different obviously kind of like the
whole
uh women supporting women type you know
thing going on there is great and
um they're able to obviously they're
gonna be able to offer
a perspective that chris couldn't offer
you know a female lead you know the
bachelorette
uh so there's there's unique taste for
sure can spice it up a little bit um
there's benefits there and
i think they're doing a great job would
you ever consider it hosting the
franchise
oh man i i don't think i'd have time for
that
going on i'd love to you know be the uh
the
the official date pilot you know flying
the cast around on on united let's
let's charter uh those flights up i'll
be down for that
okay so you're you're not trying to say
goodbye to the franchise
you'll find ways to be a part of it huh
i i've said i remember i had this in my
interview
package when i you go for like producer
weekend for the show or talk with one of
the producers
and uh we're talking yeah we're gonna
start bachelor
and i'll be and i'll be the lead pilot
for that so oh wow
bachelor yeah obviously it is really
rocky for the franchise right now
but uh there's also some necessary
conversations happening i feel like
especially when it comes to diversity
and inclusion which i feel like is
something that the show has been
criticized about for a really long time
um and you know when you announced as
the lead i felt like the show really
drove home the point that you are half
latino
uh in retrospect did you feel like that
was contrived or maybe inauthentic to
you i mean no i
i am like i'm half cuban um that's it's
been like uh you know a huge part of my
growing up and my heritage and just
what's instilled my the values that i've
been raised with
they come from you know a cuban
household and
um you know living at home until 29 like
that's just such a
stupid thing to do like that's me and
it's you know it wasn't like pushed or
you know inauthentic at all um
but no you're 100 right like they're
well i say it's sad and everything of
all like this this this
this headache essentially is going on
with everything it's it's almost
necessary there are parts that are
necessary and conversations to be had
and
obviously there has been an issue with
diversity in the franchise and um i
think
we've taken some steps and you know we
have you can't you know knock that and
that's a great thing and we got to keep
you know using that momentum moving
forward um
you know inclusion is so important
uh with all races on this show and um
there's anyone that wants to say
anything different about that it's just
flat out wrong
uh so you know i hope to to you know
that there are more conversations moving
forward and
um and there is more diversity and and
more minorities you know in
in a lead role for sure that would be
great to see